[Music]
respawn has released the first official
trailer and details for apex legends
season six boosted so let's dive into
what we know
season six's new playable legend is
rampart we get our first look at the
character in the season six cinematic
launch trailer as well as hints as to
what her abilities are
keep in mind that respawn hasn't
officially confirmed rampart's abilities
yet so this
next portion is a little bit of
guesswork don't take it as fact
rampart seems to be a defender whose
abilities help her squad lock down his
own
about halfway through the trailer we see
bangalore shooting through a laser wall
though bangalore's bullets pass through
the wall the bullet shot out or don't
in fact taking it a step further it
looks like bangalore's shots are being
amplified as they pass through the
shield
if we were to hazard a guess we think
this is rampart's tactical ability
some form of makeshift cover that helps
her and her squad mates better defend
his own
it looks a lot like the a wall a pilot
ability from titanfall 2.
sheila rampart's turret is likely her
ultimate ability
nothing quite says i'm defending this
zone like a massive chain gun
sheila might be our hint at what
rampart's passive ability is as well
especially when you consider the
character's history as an expert modder
as the trailer zooms in on rampart
firing sheila you can see a red dot
laser sight on the gun
now maybe sheila just comes with that
sight however this could also be hinting
towards rampart having a passive ability
that she mods all her weapons with the
laser sight to make it easier to aim
weapons from the hip
that would make it far easier to spray
assault rifles lmgs and smgs at an
attacking team speaking of smgs a
familiar one is coming to apex legends
in season six
respawn has confirmed that season 6's
new weapon is the volt
a fan favorite smg from titanfall 2. the
gun wasn't featured in the new trailer
so we still don't know whether it will
behave like it did in titanfall 2.
however respawn describes the volt as a
shocking new weapon which may hint that
it naturally fires disrupter rounds a
hop-up attachment that was removed from
apex legends at the start of season 3.
when season 6 launches rampart won't be
the only legend who joins the apex games
with a sense of style and knack for
crafting gadgets
season 6 adds a new crafting feature to
the game though how it will work remains
a bit
unclear respawn writes that players will
be able to find materials and craft
better gear
whether that means improving the gear
you already have or building brand new
items
hasn't been clarified in terms of the
sense of style
apex legends is getting sprays as teased
with the graffiti that appeared on the
construction signs on world's edge
you'll be able to unlock brand new holo
sprays in season 6's battle pass that's
cool and all but we want to know how
these new sprays may impact gameplay
like
can bloodhound pick up someone's tracks
from the hollow spray they leave behind
oh and speaking of those construction
signs we finally get to see what at
least some of them are for
the opening shot of the cinematic
trailer shows a rocket launch pad that's
been built just outside the dome which
is where you can currently find a
collection of construction signs the
trailer doesn't showcase what the
construction signs around drill site are
for though
now where could that rocket be going
well if you've been following the quest
storyline
for season 5 then you know the apex
games are heading to olympus a city on
the home planet of octane and lifeline
the legends are going to need some form
of transportation to get there
and perhaps this rocket is just that new
planet means a new location but respawn
hasn't confirmed whether that means a
brand new map or just
places to visit in quest come the start
of season 6. we may get a hint at season
6's quest and who trusts who
in the final shot of the trailer as well
it shows most of the legends meeting
rampart but there are a few noticeable
absentees
both revenant and loba aren't there for
instance which might hint towards how
the two are now off on their own trying
to find a way to kill
revenant caustic is absent as well which
may be in reference to his role as a
traitor in season five's quest storyline
maybe the other legends don't want to
hang out with him anymore watson is also
curiously absent though this could be
because she's still struggling to come
to terms with being betrayed in season
5. blood owned isn't there either though
as seen in an apex legends comic the
tracker excused themselves from the
group following the legends turning on
one another and not trusting each other
so perhaps bloodhound is just wary of
working with the others again
season 6 boosted is scheduled to begin
on august 18th we'll be sure to cover
the new season in full as additional
details are revealed
[Music]
you